So if naturalism is the dominant view of the West,
pantheism is the dominant view of the East.
Pantheism is interesting,
and it may seem like much of pantheistic thought
is far from your students.
And it, even though it largely dominates
the Eastern culture from Hindus to Buddhists,
and a bunch of others in that part of the world,
it has made its way to the West,
and in a really strange way.
So you might think for your youth group,
well, why are we talking about pantheism?
Why are we bothering with this?
That's another part of the world,
and I'm not taking my kids on a mission trip over there,
so do I really need to spend an entire week
dedicated to this sort of Eastern thought?
Well, do you like Star Wars?
Have you ever heard of karma, meditation, even yoga?
All of these things come from pantheistic thought,
or a pantheistic worldview.
So naturally, we cannot ignore its influence.
We have to address it, we have to discuss it,
and we gotta get our students to understand
what it exactly is so that they can identify it
and navigate through it successfully.
So what is pantheism?
What are we talking about?
So essentially, think of it this way.
The idea of God, and I'm gonna write God in a small G,
is in all.
Now, you can even say even more specifically, is all.
We talk about in Christianity,
we talk about the idea of the Holy Spirit
being within us, right?
So God is in us, and that's sort of the idea, right?
Jesus comes, Jesus goes, He sends the Spirit,
the Spirit dwells within us.
We have this idea of God in us,
not just God with us, but God in us.
Okay, that's great, but that's not the same thing
when we're talking about pantheism.
We're talking about the idea that God
is literally part of everything.
So there's, so in a pantheistic way,
God would be in me, just as much as in the camera
that I'm speaking to, as this table, as this Bible,
as this marker, as this whiteboard,
rocks, trees, pretty much all of it,
all of nature is all part of the divine.
It's all part of who God is.
It's all part of this divine sort of idea of the universe
that's all combined into one.
There's a divine spark in everything.
It's essentially what pantheism teaches.
So that's where we get this idea of essence or force.
When we talk about in Star Wars,
the idea of may the force be with you,
that same kind of idea.
It's a divine essence that's part of this.
We can call it a force.
There's something going on behind the scenes
in everything else.
So God is present everywhere.
So it defines life now, it defines life later,
it defines relationships, it defines everything,
how we see and relate to God.
But the key I want you to get here
is the idea of distinction.
And this is gonna be important
as you move forward this idea of distinction.
If naturalism is saying there's no God at all,
pantheism is saying, well, there is God,
but God is not distinct from anything that's created.
That God is a part of creation,
he's a part of you and me,
it's just as there's no distinction.
There's no God and us.
There's just everything all together.
So for pantheism, there is no distinction at all.
Okay, so keep that in the back of your mind,
especially as we move to next week
when we talk about monotheism,
that's gonna be really, really important.
So in our Bible study portion, we talk about Paul.
We talk about Paul's interaction at the Areopagus
on Mars Hill.
And we talk about his interaction
between the Epicureans and the Stoics.
And what's interesting is that these Stoics
actually believed much of the same kinds of things
that modern day pantheism believes.
That idea that God is somehow packed in
every little piece of our world.
And what Paul does, it's helps them see
that there is a distinction between the two.
That God is here and we are here.
That there's a separation,
that although he's personal,
although he's right here with us,
he's distinct and other than us.
And that's incredibly important.
Because what this does is the loss of distinction
is actually what leads us to the root of all sin, right?
Of creating God or creating idols
that are a substitute for God.
If you'd say that there's no distinction,
all of these things are just as divine as God.
So I can worship rocks and trees and everything else.
It's not any different if we don't have
some kind of distinction.
So it drives us right back to the root of our sin.
It drives us right back to idolatry.
So your students probably won't see right away,
but you need to help them begin to see
how Western culture has actually embraced
a lot of pantheistic ideas about God and creation.
Again, let's go back to the buffet.
It's super easy for us to say, wow,
it sounds really cool because I can see
how beautiful creation is
to want to make that into a God-like thing.
Or I can treat somebody or an activity
or I can find a center in myself
and be the kind of person
and elevate myself to a God-like stature.
That sounds really cool.
And along the buffet line,
sounds like I can say, well,
if I care about people,
I can elevate them to that same status too.
So I like justice.
That seems to speak to some of my morality.
That seems, you start to, again,
go back to that buffet and start to piece things together.
But when we put them all together,
we realize once again that this isn't coherent
and it isn't consistent.
Now, one quick word of note here
that I want to make sure that we're clear on.
If you're doing everything really, really well,
chances are you have some students
that are either seeking, maybe skeptical,
and get some questions and are curious.
And as we're talking about other worldviews,
whether they believe these things specifically or not,
you want to be careful that we don't offend.
We want to be careful that we speak truth,
that we do so in love,
but that we help understand that these things
are terribly inconsistent and they don't work.
But we need to do it without making fun of it.
We need to do it without making light of it.
Because when we're talking about worldviews,
as we talked about a few weeks ago,
that these things are ingrained in us
and they are embedded in us,
and to change is a huge monumental change
and can often, like we said, create some anxiety.
So the last thing we want to do
is invite non-believing students,
invite our seekers and our skeptics
into our youth space and say,
come with your questions,
come with your curiosity
and we'll help you navigate
and we're gonna accept you.
But at the same time,
we're gonna sort of make light or make fun
of other worldviews that's not gonna work.
There's, this is a very popular worldview.
So is naturalism.
So there's some really, really smart people
that have said some really, really intelligent things
about these worldviews.
Now that doesn't make them true,
but we have to respect what they believe
and speak to how it does not line up with reality
and how it does not line up with truth,
but do so in love.
So remember, pantheism, God is all.
God is in everything and a part of everything.
The rocks, the trees, everything,
and it's divine force.
And essentially, key word here is
there is no distinction between God and creation,
between creator and creation.
And not only does this lead to the idea of idolatry.
If we don't have the distinction,
what does that make God?
The very fact that we call him God
means that he is completely distinct,
completely other than and completely holy for us.
And then, or than us, the idea is
if God is here and completely other than me,
I have a standard to look to,
so I understand what's right and what's wrong.
I understand what's just and unjust.
I understand the idea of love versus hate.
Putting God outside of myself
and making God completely distinct
helps us navigate reality in a way that makes sense.
We have to have some kind of distinction.
It's God who is other than, God who is holy,
God who is supreme creator, overall.
And it's in him that we live and move and have our being.